ولرصد الاوضاع في خانيونس الان ينضم الينا
مرسل الجزيره اسماعيل ابو عمر اسماعيل
اطلعنا على التفاصيل وما الذي سجل في
الساعات الماضيه بخان
يونس ما يسجل دائما هو تكثيف لقوات
الاحتلال وطائرات الاحتلال لغارات في اكثر
من منطقه من محافظه خان يونس في هذه
اللحظات التي اتحدث معكم بها هناك غاره
جويه جديده نفذتها طائرات الاحتلال
الحربيه والتي تنشط في هذه اللحظات في
اجواء محافظه خانس بشكل مكثف قامت بغاره
على على هدف معين في وسط المحافظه تحديدا
في الاجزاء الشماليه من المنطقه الوسطى
لمحافظه خان يونس وهذه الغاره ليست الاولى
حيث منذ صباح هذا اليومفي المكان الذي
نتواجد في منطقه التحلي ومنطقه حي المناره
تتعرض هذه المناطق لعمليات قصف وغارات
جويه بين الحين والاخر اكثر من اربعه
غارات حتى الان رصدناها خلال الساعه
الاخيره في هذه المنطقه اضافه الى هذه ال
ارات ما زال المواطنون في منطقه معسكر
خانيونس يحاولون البحث عن جثامين شهداء
ارتقوا خلال الساعات الماضيه والايام
الماضيه بعد ان تراجعت اليات الاحتلال من
اكثر من محور في وسط معسكر خانيونس باتجاه
الاجزاء الغربيه من منطقه المعسكر
والمواطنون نجحوا حتى هذه اللحظه بانتشال
22 شهيدا اضافه الى عمليات انتشال اخرى في
مناطق مختلفه ومتفرقه من محافظه خانيونس
تحديدا في في منطقه الشيخ ناصر في صباح
هذا اليوم تم انتشال شهيدين اخرين من هذه
المنطقه التي تقع الى الاجزاء الجنوبيه من
محافظه خانيونس وهذه المنطقه في ظل عمليات
الانتشال الت تتم بين الحين والاخر من قبل
المواطنين ايضا تتعرض لعمليات قصف من قبل
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه منطقه منطقه
حي الامل وهي المجاوره لمنطقه المعسكر
ايضا هذه تتعرض لعمليه حصار مشدد من قبل
اليات الاحتلال في حين ان هذه الاليات
تقوم بعمليات اطلاق نار وقصف عنيف بين
الحين والاخر لمنازل المواطنين وكذلك جنود
الاحتلال يطلقون النار بين الحين والاخر
لتحركات باتجاه تحركات لمواطنين في
الشوارع المقابله تحديدا لمستشفى الامل
التابل جميه الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني في
المنطقه وكذلك هناك اصابات في صفوف
المواطنين يتم نقل هذه الاصابات التي تقع
في صفوف المواطنين تجاه نقاط طبيه يسلك
المواطنون احيانا طرقا التفافا للوصول الى
مستشفيات مستشفى ناصر تحديدا الذي يتعرض
لحصار كان خلال الساعات الماضيه اضافه الى
مستشفى الامل نفسه والذي ايضا هو محاصر من
قبل اليه الاحتلال ايضا هناك نقاط طبيه
اقيمت في الاجزاء الغربيه من محافظه
خانيونس تحديدا في منطقه المواصي هذه
النقاط تابعه للهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني
اضافه الى نقطه طبيه لوزاره الصحه يتم نقل
هذه الاصابات عبر طرق الفافيه الى هذه
النقاط ومن ثم يتم نقل هذه الاصابات من
هذه النقاط خط باتجاه مستشفيات في جنوب
قطاع غزه تحديدا في مدينه رفح او حتى في
مستشفى ميداني هنا في المنطقه الفاصله ما
بين محافظه رفح ومحافظه خانيونس عمليات
القصف مستمره المدفعيه وكذلك الغارات من
قبل طائرات الاحتلال في محافظه خانيونس في
اكثر من منطقه وفي اكثر من اتجاه
وبالتاكيد هناك حصيله دائما لهذه الغارات
هناك شهداء وهناك اصابات في مختلف المناطق
في في خانيونس اسماعيل علمنا بحسب
المعلومات بان جيش الاحتلال يستهدف اي
النازحين من خانيونس باتجاه المناطق
الاكثر جنوبا تحديدا في رفح ما الذي
تخبرنا من معلومات عن هذا
الجانب يعني في حاله التراجع التي تمت
خاصه التراجع الجزئي من قبل اليات
الاحتلال من المنطقه التي كانت تقيم فيها
نقطه تفتيش تحديدا بالقرب من جامعه الاقصى
كانت قد تراجعت هذه الاليات من هذه النقطه
فجر هذا اليوم واصبح هناك حركه لبعض
المواطنين باتجاه الغرب غرب وتجاه الشرق
بمعنى انهم دخلوا منطقه معسكر خانس بعض
المواطنين البحث عن ذويهم واهلهم بعد عره
ايام الانقطاع انقطاع التواصل وانقطاع
الاتصال معهم وهناك ايضا مواطنون كانوا
يتجهون باتجاه المناطق الغربيه منطقه
المواصي التي حددها الاحتلال بانها منطقه
امنه بحثا عن اماكن امنه اكثر بالاتجاه
سواء الى رفع او حتى المنطقه الوسطى في
دير البلح تحديدا الا ان قوات الاحتلال مع
ملاحظتها لحركه المواطنين في هذه المنطقه
هذه النقطه التي كانت تقيم فيها نقطه
تفتيش قامت صباح هذا اليوم بالعوده اليها
واغلقت الشارع وسط اطلاق نار باتجاه
المواطنين الذين تحركوا في هذا الشارع
وعلى ما يبدو بالتاكيد عمليات اطلاق النار
والقصف في محيط هذه المنطقه خاصه مع
الاعداد الكبيره من النازحين سواء
المتجهين الى الشرق الى معسكر خانيونس او
المتجهين الى الغرب الى منطقه المواصي
ايضا معرضون لعمليات اطلاق النار وقد تصيب
طلقات الناريه التي تطلقها قوات الاحتلال
المواطنين الذين تحرقون في هذا الشارع
شكرا لك اسماعيل ابو عمر مراسل الجزيره في
خان
يونس